the cow on the farm says moo moo moo the
Sheep on the farm says
ba the pig on the farm says oink oink
oink the duck on the farm says quack
quack quack Mo oink quack the horse on
the farm says nigh neigh neigh the
chicken on the farm says cluck cluck
cluck the dog on the farm says woof woof
woof the cat on the farm says meow meow
meow May cluck wolf meow not familiar
farm animals the goat on the farm says
ma ma the goose on the farm says Hulk
Hulk Hulk the turkey on the farm says
gobble gobble gobble the rooster on the
farm says cocka dooodle do my hwk Goble
cocka dooodle
Doo the rabbit on the farm says Funk
thunk Funk the donkey on the farm says
hea hea the be on the farm says buzz
buzz buzz the mouse on the farm says
squeak squeak squeak he h bu
squeak the pigeon on the farm
says the Frog on the farm says ribbit
ribbit ribbit the Lamb on the farm
says the cow on the farm says moo moo
moo cool Ribbit by
moo the on the farm says ho ho ho the
crow on the farm says co co co the
duckling on the farm says beep beep beep
the head on the farm says clock clock
clock who got PE
[Music]
clu the peacock on the farm says scream
scream scream the llama on the farm says
hum hum hum the guinea steak on the Farm
says squeal squeal squeal the turkey on
the farm says Goble Goble go scream hum
squeal
Goble the pony on the farm says neigh
neigh neigh the bull on the farm says
snort snort snort the chick on the farm
says cheat che che the dove on the farm
says c c n snort cheek
C animals sing all day
long with Mose and N in there happy
song hey
[Music]